j'accueille maintenant jean luc
mélenchon
t'as vu
alors jean luc mélenchon bonsoir votre
ex julien dray était ici la semaine
dernière et il nous a raconté comment
vous l'avez quittée pour henri
emmanuelli et à quel point il a été
malheureux jusqu'à vous refusez un
cachet et l'histoire politique de
l'année en chine s'est elle l'attend
comment c'est possible un truc pareil on
était deux dans un coin hein
personne ne nous voyait sur ma petite
boîte de cachou jeu la pause je vais me
cacher ah oui j'ai toujours est caché et
et alors il me dit non non j'en veux pas
bon et puis tout d'un coup je retrouve
ça dans la presse à la télé enfin c'est
une histoire de fou et sa rive nord le
catch ou mat c'est terrible quand vous
êtes à votre nouveau monde avec
emmanuelli pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
embarquer julien juger votre copain
quand même venus
pourquoi vous avez les serrures ont pas
ce qu'ils voulaient pas c'était pas son
truc à elle voulait pas non mais
moratoire comme je l'avais surpris avec
un autre 1 le week end dernier donc
julien dray n'était pas à argelès dans
la salle polyvalente de la mairie fort à
l'endroit où a été portée sur les fonts
baptismaux votre nouveau courant avoué à
emmanuelli qui s'appelle le nouveau
monde
il a dû se marrer julien dray parce que
dès le lendemain
l'appellation nouveaux mots en effet
protesté par une association de
retraités qui s'appelle comme ça c'est
terrible
pendant qu'un nouveau mouvement le
lendemain il ya des seniors qui hurle
c'est terrible je vais changer de nom
vous avez pris quelques conseillers en
communication sur le robert hue qui
arrive aux gens voilà ce qui arrive aux
gens ce contrat de conseil en
communication qui laissent parler leur
coeur animal monde il ya des retraités
qui s'appelle nouveau monde tant mieux
pourquoi vous allez rester nouveau monde
quand même
ah ouais moi je trouve ça bien j'aime çà
çà çà une dimension de de découverte
d'une belle page blanche voilà il ya
quelque chose de poétique là dedans la
politique c'est pas forcément sinistre 1
enfin pour moi voilà lorsqu'on peut dire
j vigan pour ses cli d2 de jean-luc
mélenchon et d'henri emmanuelli c'est de
créer un nouveau courant sans julien au
sein du parti socialiste pour donner un
coup de barre à gauche et bourses virent
et de la direction du parti et
blairistes c'est à dire les fabius les
dominique strauss kahn n'est pas moi qui
le dit roland ça c'est moi mais bon moi
j'ai déjà gagné vie les a traités de
solférino dactyle c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal je fais attention à ce que je
dis parce que le peu que j'en ai dit la
semaine dernière ça fait toute une
esbroufe parce que j'ai fait des petites
plaisanteries crêpes enchaînements oui
mais la politique il y a une dimension
sérieuse 1 et d'ailleurs vous les médias
ces enjeux dit vous ne devrait pas
généraliser mais en général c'est pas ce
qui intéresse j'ai parlé pendant une
demi-heure et on a retenu dans la presse
une petite phrase parce que hein je suis
parti vous savez j'étais en train de
critiquer bon il ya deux points de vue
dans le parti socialiste en point de vue
qui est d'accompagnement de la
mondialisation libérale et de l'autre
côté le point de vue que je représente
est pris à ceux qui sont au milieu qui
veulent pas tranché alors ils sont ni ni
ni ni
et alors je suis parti dans ni
et de nini je suis passé à nini naf naf
n'ouvre pas ce que je me rappelle
l'histoire des trois petits cochons
c'est pas mal oui mais il faut voir
l'histoire ce que ça fait oui mais
attendez je vais vous dire un truc bien
une fonction tribunitienne dans la
politique qui existe qu'elle allie merci
de le dire café cirque aujourd'hui des
hommes politiques souvent j'ai un
discours d'experts comptables moi je
trouve ça plus rigolo non mais
sérieusement vous a plus rigolo quand tu
as un mec qui vient depuis qu'il fait
des cds phrase qui nous fait un peu
vibrer quoi c'est ça la politique
n'existe plus avant l'assemblée
nationale et moins jusqu'aux je parle
comme je sens le la lors il ya des
moments où c'est plaisant il ya d'autres
mots c'est plus grave ya des choses qui
m'émeuvent et j'en parle bon hélas mais
mes petits camarades il sait si du
poisson ou aux phillies et l'amif remy
bouillie laisse tomber dans l'oreille ou
proches allaient enfin comme je sais que
je vais arrêter de fumer
1 j'ai arrêté de fumer donc terriblement
nerveux il vaut mieux les quelques
plongées avec sérieusement au congrès
vous aurez avec vous 30 40 % des
militants a à peu près parce que c'est
vrai que les militants sont plus à
gauche
la direction artistique avec des gens de
gauche de démarrer c'est vrai la
discussion
mais c'est l'agent lui à gré des soucis
au ps les militants sont plus à gauche
que que les patrons enfin que ceux qui
dirigent actuellement bref donc 30 40 %
après vous prenez un petit peu je pas dû
martine aubry du monde bourg et vous
faites une majorité donc vous prenez la
direction du ps imagine mal élu mais
quand même c'est quand vous êtes au
pouvoir après le pib ya rien d'abord le
pays lui il bute en train de se
droitiser donc elle se les faire avec
votre direction boulanger c'est ça le
problème en est c'est pas un marché la
politique on n'est pas là à dire la
voilà j'ai amené mon petit chiffon bleu
qui est-ce qui on veut mon petit chiffon
vert convaincre la partie politique
c'est fait pour ça et au début vous avez
des idées qui sont pas forcément
populaires parce que les idées qui vont
de soi c'est la vie de tous les jours
donc on ne change rien ça va comme ça
moi je pense qu'on peut changer les
choses quand on convint quand on
entraîne un
un mouvement et quand on est quand on a
le courage de ses idées tout à l'heure
là moi je vais vous faire un reproche on
a parlé du front national mais bien sûr
j'ai si j'ai fait campagne avec charlie
hebdo de s'expliquer il faut oser dire
aux français la république et par un
régime neutre et il y en a marre de
cette comédie à la fois on lui verse une
partie de l'argent de nos impôts pour le
financer on accepte qui se présentent à
des élections et puis quand il arrive au
deuxième tour tout le monde se met à
crier au loup et et voilà des gens comme
moi qui se retrouvent à aller voter
chirac alors que j'aime mieux vous dire
que ça m'a coûté un peu de théorie et
bien écoutez ça suffit si c'est des
ennemis de la démocratie on interdise
partie parce que la république est pas
un régime ne vous si c'est pas des
ennemis on le dit on arrête ses
conneries
donc en fait donc fabius et dominique
strauss kahn hollande tout ça vous dit
ils ont accepté la mondialisation
libérale
ils combattent pour que cette
mondialisation libérale soit la moins
mauvaise pour les gens vouloir
reconnaissez ça comme un voile oui bien
sûr bien sûr
en fait la vraie ligne de fracture elle
passe au sein du parti socialiste ça se
trouve entre ceux qui acceptent de la
mondialisation libérale en voulant
qu'elle soit pas trop dur pour les gens
et de l'autre côté ceux qui la refusent
de neiger vous donner un exemple qu'on
passait un peu abstrait comme ça par
exemple sur le lac est ce qu on accepte
ou pas d'ouvrir une partie d'edf capital
privé moi je dis non rien pas un mètre
c'est fini on n'arrête plus de
privatiser cauxois d'odile oui mais il
faut tenir compte de l'environnement
on est obligé de faire comme les autres
mais attention on va le faire mais en
même temps prendra des précautions et
puis au bout de deux ans trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans vous étiez
détricoter tout le pull-over et vous
vous retrouvez qu'un france télécom qui
est dans le trou alors qu'on nous avait
chanté monts et merveilles sur
l'ouverture du capital de france télécom
sur le vf on peut pas dire en tous les
cas que le fait que edf soit
nationalisée lui interdit de mener des
djeun ventura l'étranger parce qu'il
oeuvrait déjà le fait déjà donc pourquoi
ce qui est incroyable c'est que si les
gens comme moi qui se font prendre à
partie on dit le mélenchon vous êtes en
doctrinaire vous défendre les services
publics mais aux autres on pose pas la
question de savoir pourquoi ils veulent
ouvrir le capital pour quoi faire
puisque ça marche
si ça fonctionne c'est eux qui sont en
réalité des dogmatiques et puis alors
pour le coup c'est vraiment d
des staline au libéra un libéro vous
n'êtes pas le roi de la ramener si vous
faites une critique aussitôt vous êtes
habillé pour l'hiver archaïque passé
tout ce qui est ce qui est moderne c'est
de libéraliser c'est tout transformé en
marchandise savoir si c'est moderne mais
moi je pense que c'est pour le coup
c'est ce qui est plus archaïque c'est ce
qui est plus rétro et en plus ça marche
pas si ça marchait il pourrait nous dire
on va regarder comme on y arrive enfin
c'est quand même la californie quand
même et à développer s'est retrouvé dans
le noir n'ont pas la france 1 il
étrangle l'étrangler qui marchent pas
les hôpitaux anglais qui marchent pas
enfin et pourtant les anglais sont pas
plus bêtes que d'autres à l'époque on
prenait inter on disait vivement que ce
soit démilitarisé et rivaliser
maintenant il ya un liberty sont encore
plus en retard car inter d'accord voilà
mais ça fait donc angleterre inter
pensez à vous ça fait du bien d'entendre
ça parce que pendant des années on a eu
l'impression se demandait si on voulait
ça fout on disait mais bon peut-être que
finalement ce tronc puisqu'ils disent
tous la même chose
peut-être qu'on se trompe et l'ampleur
de la catastrophe derrière ça fait froid
dans le dos les français se rendent pas
compte séparé non à l'argentine par
exemple il n'ya pas un terroriste
il n'y a pas un communiste n'a pas un
révolutionnaire à l'horizon le pays
s'est fracassée faut savoir l'argentine
c'est un pays développé
c'est un pays qui était ni jo de
l'italie un sur pied par terre les gens
les gens ne savent plus quoi faire on
fabrique des billets en écrivant dessus
pour échanger les qui s'est passé en
argentine récemment il ya un camion qui
transportait des boeufs qui a eu un
accident le camion s'est renversé et les
gens sont venus avec des couteaux alors
que les argentins c'est un peuple s'est
développée savage ils sont arrivés avec
des couteaux et ils ont découpé les
boeufs au bord de la route pour pouvoir
manger voilà où il en sort n'en sont ils
engrangent de l'airé champ à cause du
fmi